where is the point on the number line
here we have a number line that starts
at 1.5 or one and five tenths and goes
to one and seven tenths
so the distance between these larger
blue tick marks is one tenth because we
go from one and five-tenths to one and
six-tenths so that went up a tenth and
then up to one and seven-tenths
so this distance here
this distance here
is one-tenth
or we could write that as a decimal
one-tenth
or as a fraction one-tenth that distance
between each of these blue large tick
marks is a tenth
but we want to know what is this green
point right here
so to figure that out we also need to
figure out what do these black tick
marks represent these smaller distances
so from here to here is one tenth
and within that tenth there are one two
three 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 equal spaces
so each of these little spaces
is 1 10
1 10 of this distance because it's one
of the ten equal spaces
so this
right here is a this right here is a
tenth
of this tenth
because the large distance is a tenth
and this is one tenth of that tenth
another way we could say that is a one
hundredth
a tenth of a tenth if you take one tenth
and divide it into ten pieces now you
have a one hundredth
so this distance is a one hundredth
which means that each of these distances
this is another hundredth and another
hundredth so how many hundredths till we
get to our point
let's see one hundredth two three four
five six seven
seven hundredths is what it took us to
get there so we could say seven
hundredths the fraction
or the decimal
0.07 with a seven in the hundredths
place
so looking at the whole number line now
putting the whole thing together
we started at 1.5
or one and five tenths
and we went another seven hundredths so
we can write that as plus
seven
hundredths
so we have one and five tenths plus
seven more hundredths which is a total
of one
and fifty seven hundredths or one point
five seven
so our point right here is at one point
one and five tenths
plus seven more hundredths gets us to
one and fifty seven hundredths